So the Object.create technique seems to be the only that doesn't have
adverse side effects.
Finally, we need to make the grab method available on all Van instances without
making that method available on any of the Car instances that are not Vans.
As usual, we will add the properties that we want to be available on
all instances of a class to the prototype object that is stored as a property on
the constructor function.
And it seems like we'd be all done,
but there's one thing missing that belongs right here.
Can you think of anything that we might of undermined, as a result of the fact
that we overrode the prototype object with a brand new object we created?
Looking at the diagram for a moment.
Remember, that this object that we placed at the key.prototype on
our Van function, replaced an object that came for free with the Van function.
So is there anything you can remember about the original object that was
special and important and might need to be put back?